what's going on guys this is Rob and
just in time for
Halloween we are back with dark X-Men
these are like the Demonic X-Men so
picking up off the last video which
again as always there'll be a link to
the fall of X playlist at the end of
this you can click on to get caught up
we basically pick up with this kind of
alternate reality story of meline Prior
now the long and short of meline for
those of you guys who aren't familiar
with her she was basically a clone of
Jean Gray Right In fact when she was
originally created it was Chris
claremont's desire to get rid of Jean so
originally Cyclops was going to marry
meline prior and then ride off into the
sunset such as it was after the dark
Phoenix Saga genan gray was so popular
Marvel brought her back but the idea
behind meline is that in the main Marvel
Universe she had basically made a deal
with demons and then launched attack
against the city of New York in the
original Inferno storyline not to be
confused with Jonathan Hickman's Inferno
in this story this version of meline
Prior never stopped right she was well
seemingly never defeated and in effect
limbo had basically overtaken Earth now
the difference here is that this meline
as a lot of you guys had called ahead of
time basically comes from Secret Wars in
2015 when the Multiverse collapsed and
Dr Doom used the powers of the beyonders
to save whatever he could this world was
one of the universes that was saved and
so this version of meline Prior rules
Limbo with an iron fist but she is very
dark and very very Twisted any human
element of her that used to be a part of
her is basically gone she's a full-on
demon at this point this version of
Nightcrawler is much the same way and
that's one of the big differences
between that alternate reality version
of meline and the one that we normally
see is that this Dark Twisted version of
meline is very deep into black magic
right she is exceedingly evil and so
what's going on here is that in addition
to all of this in the last video Warren
Worthington Archangel had basically been
defeated and was presumed left for dead
ultim ultimately he was taken by the
forces of orcus who again are hunting
down mutants across the world and
brought to meline for her to use her
magic and then basically imbue him with
whatever power he needs in order to help
orcus take down whatever forces are out
there now one of the things that
longtime readers of Marvel Comics will
be picking up on pretty quickly is that
Marvel is very much leaning into a lot
of the old school Days of Future Past
Age of Apocalypse kind of plot devices
right using mutants to hunt mutants so
again it's really one of these age-old
elements of the Marvel landscape and
everything old is new again now the
other part of this is Alex Summers the
brother of Cyclops also known as Havoc
he was severely injured and in fact it
looked like he was going to die but he's
taken by the main Marvel Universe meline
prior who uses some pretty dark magic
and basically finds a way to effectively
try to resurrect him or at the very
least Stave off death right keep him
alive for a period of time
now something to understand about magic
in Marvel Comics is that it does come
with a kind of price what this price is
can range and really has a lot to do
with the plot device that's going on for
example when Doctor Strange tried to
sell 100% of his soul for absolute power
basically the power of God during
Avengers and New Avengers because of the
fact that magic corrupts the soul
dealing with black magic things like
that which he had done in the past his
soul was corrupted so he could not sell
100% of his soul right just things along
those lines with the character of Alex
Summers we don't know exactly how far
reaching this is going to be all we know
is that it's going to have some kind of
an effect on his powers now for the
other members of the team a zazil the
father of Nightcrawler which you can
probably obviously tell by his physical
appearance zero who is basically a
mutant that has the ability to transform
his body into virtually anything he
wants to and in fact merge into other
people's bodies as well which he'll do
with the robot version of Wolverine
Albert
as he's known they all kind of start
fracturing a little bit and the reason
for this is because this is a team
that's a combination of Heroes villains
and anti-villains for a character like
Carmen Cruz she's relatively new to all
of this so for her she doesn't really
fall into either category she's just
kind of a person that's just sort of
here and she's young and learning about
all this stuff matteline prior has
historically been a villain but in this
instance I guess she's more of an
anti-hero Alex Summers this guy's down
back for mine prior so he'll go wherever
she goes Gambit of course is an
anti-hero so on and so forth right the
list goes on and on and on but the thing
here is that not all of them agree with
the actions of madelin because as we
covered in the previous video madelin
has no qualms with killing she has no
issues with doing that right so if some
Rogue group some orcus team decides to
attack them she'll have them all
annihilated people like Gambit are a
little on the fence about it like that's
not really what the X-Men stand for but
the reality here is that mad prior is
kind of right right extreme
circumstances call for Extreme Measures
right extreme actions and so for her
it's not a matter of what's left of the
mutant population trying to run and hide
and so on it's let's go on the offensive
and take the fight to them but be
equally bad in order to ensure that we
win right otherwise our morality will be
our handicap right it's very much a
philosophical argument there but what's
also really interesting here is that
we're introduced to a couple of
characters that we haven't really seen
before the first one is crawl and the
second one is valon now these are two
people who are working directly with
orcus but they're kind of like a special
team right which is to say that sure
orcus as a gigantic organization is
tracking down mutants but much like we
talked about with the idea of mutants
hunting mutants different things like
that that orcus is working with people
that are very Cloak and Dagger very
mysterious likely have some ties to the
mutant population itself but because of
their capabilities specifically these
guys and tracking down and capturing
meline PRI because this alternate
version of mine prior she did reappear
in the main Marvel Universe in a really
Trash Story literally they were
launching an attack and trying to
conquer Earth using a cargo container in
Florida as a base of operations it was
one of just the most ridiculous Concepts
ever in the history of Marvel Comics it
was
dumb but that's how they managed to
capture her right these folks are just
incredibly capable we don't really know
the level of power that they have what
we do know is that because Albert the
robot version of wolver rain is a robot
what it does do is it allows Collin
Valen to actually spy on madelin prior's
team with them being none the wiser now
one of the things that goes on here is
again zero does merge with this version
of Wolverine which is really kind of
wonky but the reality is that the
charter of the mission Remains the Same
that for meline prior and her dark X-Men
the idea is to go out there into the
world and find different mutants that
are fleeing from orcus that have
remained on Earth that are trapped here
in trying to find some measure of Safe
Haven but what's wild about this is that
she actually splits the team in two one
team ends up going after the uh morlocks
which we'll cover here in a second
because those poor guys they can't catch
a break but the other team is tasked
with going after Marisol and in fact
Carmen is sent after Marisol now the
reason why is because Marisol is Young
Carmen's young the belief of mine prior
is that Carmen could actually resonate
and most likely talk to Marisol in a way
that nobody else could because Marisol
would just attack the rest so again it's
a really really cool element and Marisol
is a pretty underrated character but
what end up going on as we transition
over to the morlocks the team's led by
Kalisto now Kalisto is a long-standing
member of Marvel Comics and she's been
the leader of the morlocks for quite
some time one of the cooler story arcs
that happened with their character back
in the day is that storm one of the
field commanders of the X-Men under
Cyclops had actually defeated Kalisto in
one-on-one combat in order to determine
the leadership of the morlocks what
ended up happening is of course once
storm W in order to allow Kalisto to
maintain her honor and to maintain that
kind of connection between the two she
allowed Kalisto to kind of be the quote
unquote field commander of the morlocks
so in essence she was still leader of
the team right she still led the
morlocks as a whole but these guys can
never catch a break man whether it's
like the mutant Massacre when Sinister
sends a forces into the sewers of New
York to Massacre the morlocks or any
number of things man they just can't be
left alone because what happens here is
that while they're just kind of out
there on a boat basically avoiding any
and everybody somebody swoops in and
just like takes two of them out Cuts one
of them in half only for us to find out
it's a reworked version of Archangel
he's been modified and warped by the
alternate reality version of meline
Prior which what's really cool to see is
that he's actually actually got his
metallic Wings back right we don't know
if they're actually adamantium or some
kind of organic metal that's similar to
what he's used in the past but
regardless he just takes these guys out
in one Fell Swoop now from there gamut
and his forces kind of respond as best
they can but against someone like Warren
Worthington who has the ability to fly
that's where the difficulty comes into
play Under normal circumstances Warren
Worthington isn't really anybody that
matters when it comes to power he is
exceedingly rich and and it's because of
that amount of money that he had that
when you looked at things like the
original X Factor he was able to
bankroll the team but outside of that
man the guy has like some angel wings
and he can fly rahu right I mean it's by
no standard of
measurement you know anything that makes
him fantastic what does make him cool is
when he was originally Horseman death
his original wings were ripped off and
replaced with metal wings and then in
turn he just became this wildly deadly
guy because this dude who can fly around
shoot metal wings at you right attack
you from a distance it makes them pretty
formidable especially in the face of
people who cannot fly what can they do
right it's like being mowed down by a
helicopter or a jet or something along
those lines and so the best they can do
is hold off against Warren Worthington
until like Gambit can concoct a plant
now at that point you switch over to
Mexico with the arrival of mine PRI
Albert Alex Summers and Carmen to meet
with marasol now Marisol is incredibly
powerful and she's one of these mutants
that a lot of people sleep on in terms
of what she can do the reason for this
is because she has the ability to
manipulate plant life now on the surface
that doesn't really seem impressive at
all but because she can manipulate plant
life she can make any plants of any kind
grow in any location specifically in
this instance she has plants growing
that start emitting these pheromones
right these kind of spores that
basically knock everybody out and that's
only a taste of what she can do she can
basically grow plants she can create
plants by merging plant species right
things that aren't native or aren't
natural to the world so she can create
plants that emit spores that drive you
insane that could take away your powers
that could force you to see things that
aren't there that could alter your
perception of the world around you
create hallucinations I mean it's all
kinds of stuff that she can do to say
nothing of simply just manipulating
plant life in its natural form so again
it doesn't seem overly impressive but
given the right kind of Storyteller she
would be able to take out most any and
all teams that exist out there and so
during this time different members of
the dark X-Men kind of experienced these
hallucinations we don't really see what
everybody sees we only really see what
meline sees which is her kind of
revisiting her own past learning she's a
clone of Gan gray so on and so forth not
a whole lot doing there right I mean if
you don't really know anything about her
history I guess it's kind of interesting
but even if you do know about her
history it's not really interesting at
all because you know I mean outside of
her being a villain the old school
stories with her are not all that
fantastic FC but for Carmen walking up
and talking to Marisol this creates a
kind of connection between the two
because what Marisol has done is by
using her powers and manipulating plant
life she's created this gigantic barrier
that cannot be easily overcome now one
of the things that I do want to point
out here is that this appearance of her
and the role she's playing Marisol
basically says like I visited kcoa for a
little while but I have no desire to go
back right like even if I could go back
I don't really want to I mean it was
kind of cool for what it was but the
reality here is that it was all politics
they were doing some shady stuff and
they were right like the quiet Council
on ccoa was kind of presented as this
governing body that was there for the
betterment of the mutant population but
it was very much a kind of orwellian
everybody's equal but some are more
equal than others type philosophy right
so again rules for thee not for me and
so it was really really weird in terms
of how it function and how they kind of
made it work but the reality here is
that for folks like Marisol she had no
desire to return even then when you have
like orcus hunting down the mutant
population this is just kind of an
instance of what's going on and you guys
noticed that over the course of us
covering the entirety of the fall of X
event you find these small little
pockets of the mutant population across
the world some of them are resistance
Fighters others are just hiding out and
just waiting until the whole thing blows
over hoping that basically somebody else
saves them because that's really what
meol is doing she's keeping people safe
but at the end of the day like what's
the end game here right like what's the
end goal here and it's just wait right
just wait things out and hope that
somebody comes and brings an end to all
of this so that Mirasol and her ilk can
kind of come out and say okay cool
thanks for saving us let's go back to
life as normal right so again it's the
smart move depending on you know how you
see things and what you're what you're
doing here but for Carmen and Marisol
because they're both young because
they're both youthful and in a lot of
ways they're caught up in a circumstance
they can't really understand for the
most part Carmen starts kind of
traveling around and visiting the local
people right she's the only only one
who's really allowed in by marasol
because it's really the only person that
marasol trusts now what's also going on
here is that in addition to the forces
of Gambit and his guys dealing with
Archangel that you basically have meline
prior's evil version sending out the
Nightcrawler clone or the Nightcrawler
you know Monster if you want to call him
that basically a warped and twisted
version of Kurt Wagner from that
alternate reality from limbo and so once
he starts teleporting around again he's
just a straight up demonic entity there
is no there's no like Kurt Wagner as we
know him trapped inside this guy's mind
he's just straight up in an animalistic
State and so he's just kind of
teleporting around and attacking
everybody that he can but then he comes
to this realization that what he should
be doing is actually going after Carmen
going after these mutants who were here
now again all of this is done at the
direction of like crawl and valins and
so on but orcus itself why go after
meline prior and her forces when there's
a whole host of these unarmed mutants
that exist on the other side of this
plant wall that this thing can go after
and basically wipe out almost instantly
due to its ability to teleport around
and so on and so forth so that's exactly
what it does now Carmen does step in
right she steps in she attacks this
thing and she's able to hold it off
momentarily just long enough for her to
realize it can't easily overtake her and
then it teleports away but do not be
fooled right it's not as though she
defeated this thing it was a
reconnaissance Mission kill what you can
where you can but it was a recon mission
that by getting there teleporting around
and seeing what all is going on one it
ends up gaining valuable information on
what meline prior's team is capable of
and two now it knows the location of A
Safe Harbor because what Marisol does is
in response to this she says get your
team and leave get out of here right
because they didn't know we were here
before now they do which means we're
going to have to pack up and we're going
to have to leave or we're going to have
to fortify our defenses but you've just
made us a Target right your team that's
out there to quote unquote save people
is doing nothing but just revealing
other people's locations to orcus
whether you intend to or not and so the
response of meline is fine right if you
don't want my help then I won't give you
my help right there are others quote
unquote more deserving but that's the
nature of Madeline is because she spends
too much time focusing on the fact that
she thinks she's right and never accepts
the possibility that she might be wrong
right it's one of the big failings of
her character over the years in Marvel
now she's written to be that way right
it's her arrogance and so on and so
forth but what ends up happening is that
the response of orcus is to say okay
fine and I don't know exactly how I feel
about this if this is the route that
we're going to take right if what we
have to do is find a way to take out
meline prior and then her team will be
easy pickings then let's go after
somebody that she's close to perhaps the
only person that she actually cares
about out there they end up going to
track down Ben Riley and the question
has to be asked what happens when this
happens because remember Ben Riley is a
clone of Spider-Man he has all the
powers of spider Spiderman so the
question to ask is if a version of
Spider-Man starts working with orcus or
becomes a target of orcus and ends up
going after mine prior what happens
right what happens with all of this
presumably it'd be an answer to the
question what if Spider-Man were hunting
the Xmen It's pretty dope but with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this to an end as always make sure you
click this link to the fall of X
playlist if you need to get caught up
and I will catch you all later peace